hello again now police are warning of
serious disruption throughout the day as
protesters target motorways in a
demonstration over high fuel prices long
motorway cues are forming already as
rolling roadblocks have brought parts of
the m4 to a standstill police have
reduced the speed on the carriageway to
around 10 miles an hour protesters
mainly targeting three lane motorways in
wales scotland
england as well they're calling for a
cut in fuel duty to help with rising
petrol costs well the average cost of
petrol now
191.5 pence per liter up slightly from
over the weekend and a rise of half a
pence compared to last week as you can
see there meanwhile the average price of
diesel is now 199 pence per liter a
slight dip since the weekend but it's
continued to rise in the last seven days
by 0.1
well joining me now is the founder of
fairfield uk howard cox thanks very much
for your time this morning howard um do
you support these protests
i do support them if they are lawful and
they do not interfere with emergency
services
and i was assured by that i'm nothing to
do them it's a
social media driven one a disparate
group of people who have basically fed
up to the back team with how much their
their cost to fill their cars their
their vans and their trucks but but i
provided they actually don't do a lawful
protest i will back them
and we were all fed up with a high price
of petrol but punishing other drivers
doesn't really seem to be the way to
sort out the problem does it well that's
the point but i mean what we're talking
about i understand from them is that
they're going on the go slow so you can
still get around at the moment in time
and provided they don't impact an
emergency services and people going
about their day they might lose about 20
minutes to half an hour in the day
because of these protests but it's got
to be brought home to the government
that these pump prices are unsustainable
and crippling the economy and crippling
crippling peoples and small businesses
lives
but going slow as we can see in these
pictures means using more fuel adding to
the problem
yeah okay i take your point we can go on
about this all the time but the
government and their economic torpo
torpo and their inertia regarding do
anything about this they've got to cut
fuel duty by at least uh 20p in germany
that's been cut by 25p in spain by uh
20p in ireland 17p and france 13p our 5p
in the spring statement in march didn't
even touch the sides we have to
recognize the fact that this is the
commercial heartbeat of any economy is
fuel and logistics and uh uh
travel these are the sort of things the
government are not recognizing and they
should be doing something about it and a
conservative government who's uh not
actually recognizing this uh they should
be hanging their heads in shame well
hang on a minute rishi sunaku said he
will carefully consider calls for a more
substantial fuel duty cut what does
carefully consider mean it's been like
this for a long time i've been
campaigning for 13 years we've managed
to get a freezing duty since 2011 and we
got a cut in 2011 of a penny with george
osborne we got a five p cup this uh
spring statement just happened in 2022
but it's not impacted we're still the
highest tax drivers in the world and i
repeat germany have cut fuel duty by 25
people we need to do the same to get our
economy motoring sorry about the ban
who's your frustration mostly directed
at is it the government or is it also um
the refineries the wholesalers those
people who can also keep prices high
well we've got three ask and so you can
ask your question both the government
and also the fuel supply chain
we've got three asks and one of them
you've already heard me say is the 20p
cutting duty another one is to introduce
a body called pump watch which we think
because there's 37 million drivers and
there's no consumer price protection for
them they've got no idea when oil prices
go up or go down what they'll be paying
in a few weeks later at the pumps
there's no logic no one understands the
calculation it's
completely at the whim of these big oil
companies and uh large wholesalers it's
not the small independent retailers
they're not making a lot of money it's
further up the fuel supply chain so we
need a body called pump watch and we've
also we've managed to get our third ass
which is the cma inquiry into the
profiteering further up the fuel supply
chain uh quasi carton is written to the
cma to demand that inquiry take place
and ask why that 5p cutting fuel chief
he wasn't passed on to drivers on the
day of the spring statement
it does strike me um as a motorist that
um uh petrol stations are very quick to
put prices up when there are issues like
we're seeing at the moment but it takes
them a lot longer to bring things down
when the situation eases well that's the
rocket and feather syndrome we've always
seen this before for years and years and
years and that's why we need these
bodies we need pump watch we need a cma
inquiry and making sure that enquires
not a whitewash like the last one in
2013 which it was a whitewash uh what we
need is some serious teeth from this
government and let's get back to some
proprietary policies by cutting taxes to
help people incentivizing the economy
what advice have you got for for
motorists who are shopping around for
the uh for the best price to fill up
well in answer to your point about the
fact of driving is using more fuel
etcetera it is you've got to look at the
various apps and petrolprices.com
organizations like that you can see
where price is the lowest price etc
supermarkets are still the cheaper
versions but they're not as cheap as
they used to be because they're involved
in much more being taken over by
commercial entities that are more profit
driven rather than customer driven so
i'm sorry to say i'm afraid we're going
to see oil prices continue to go up i'm
sorry to say that fan price is going to
remain high unless the government cut
the all duty now
okay we'll see what the chancellor has
to say in coming days and weeks howard
cox founder of fairfuel uk thank you
very much